this video is for language teachers if  you don't know who i am my name is  blossom i use they them pronouns  i'm an educational consultant for your  sexuality and i specifically did my  research on transgender people's  attitudes towards pronoun usage in their  native and additional languages and this  is me telling you okay first of all  non-binary people exist oh man  people are creating language that they  don't have to adhere to the gender  binary so we as language teachers what  is non-binary how do you exist if you  can't even define it  need to be teaching our students giving  our students access to this language  especially for non-binary students  regardless of if that language is  accepted by a linguistic regulatory body  okay i don't have kids i don't have  children but if i did i swear to god if  this teacher pulled up it'd be a nayski  nayski from me they wanted to teach my  kids gender-neutral pronouns oh no oh no